we're in production on the Marvels the
sequel to Captain Marvel
it's full comic book Madness it's going
to be follows like how do these three
people learn to become a team
[Music]
I spend the Animated Series
[Music]
audience means so much to us the show is
very special and I think it's going to
make a big difference in people's lives
again
there's still more to say more to do
I can't wait for you to see the brand
new worlds on the horizon
[Music]
see you soon
[Music]
what is up everybody tomorrow is the big
day Disney's d23 Expo and Marvel
studios's panel where they're going to
give us all of their big reveals So
today we're going over my final
predictions for d23 what Marvel Studios
is actually going to reveal to us at the
Expo now all of this is coming from
things that I've heard some are from
actual people some are rumors online but
essentially this is what I actually
think is going to go down at d23
tomorrow and yes I am expecting it to be
big before sdcc a lot of us were trying
to level the expectations and say hey it
might not be that big and then it ended
up being huge I think it's going to be
the same for d23 and if you're wondering
what time it starts at it starts at 10
A.M tomorrow Saturday September 10th and
that's 10 a.m Pacific time I do not
think they're going to be live streaming
it anywhere but Disney invited the
cosmic Wonder so I sent somebody and
they're going to be texting me the whole
entire time so be sure to subscribe hit
that notification Bell because I'll be
covering everything that happens
tomorrow plus I'll be tweeting and
posting on Instagram about it as well if
you want to follow me there now here's
the official Disney description of what
is happening tomorrow during the hall
d23 presentation it says Hall d23
presentation welcome all multiversal
Intergalactic and World spanning
adventurers as Marvel Studios lucasfilm
and 20th Century Studios preview
upcoming titles including sneak peeks
and special guests so bring on the sneak
peeks and please Marvel Studios release
them to the public and as far as I know
this is going to run about an hour and a
half which means Marvel Studios is
probably going to get 30 to 45 minutes
to talk about upcoming projects now what
I think they're going to focus on is a
little bit of the latter half of the
phase five projects the ones that have
just been announced like Captain America
new world order the Thunderbolts
Daredevil born again and then I think
they're going to go on to phase six and
reveal the rest of what is coming now
I've already done videos talking about
possible trailers that we could see and
talking about other phase five projects
we won't go too deep into that in this
video because I really want to talk
about what I expect for phase six and
again this is just my final predictions
based off of everything that we've heard
over the past few weeks now as you saw
in the video in the beginning Disney is
putting a big emphasis on Marvel Studios
teasing it on the floor at d23 right now
and that video was posted on Twitter by
user at August braro so credit to her
for that but that's a pretty good
indication of what we're gonna see
there's some new logos for some new
projects like Captain America new world
order so like I said they'll go over a
little bit of phase five but then dive
into phase six hopefully revealing the
rest of the slate and based off of
everything that we've heard this week
here's what I think is about to go down
one of course is Deadpool 3. I think
this is a given we know they've been
working on it for a long time Ryan
Reynolds has been working on the script
actually for years now they now have the
writing team they have the director and
it seems like they know what the movie
is going to be about the latest rumors
say that they're actually going to be
bringing over some Fox X-Men into our
universe not to kind of be there
permanently but to just kind of partake
in secret Wars and there's actually been
a rumored release date going around that
says that Deadpool could be coming
February of 2024. I'm not too sure about
that I'm not sure what the rumor comes
from or if it's just posted to an online
board somewhere but I do expect them to
announce Deadpool tomorrow with an
official release date so we'll find out
soon enough now my next prediction is
World War Hulk this seems to be a given
right now if you have watched She-Hulk
so far I won't spoil anything but they
really did set up the Hulk for a future
storyline in the MCU rumor has it that
the rights from Universal went back to
Disney so they can now do a solo Hulk
film and it's been reported I think over
a year now that Marvel Studios is
developing a Hulk story that is based
off of world war Hulk and Planet Hulk
from the comics and based off of what
we've seen in She-Hulk it does seem like
that is the storyline and it does seem
like the Hulk could even have a sun scar
rumor has it that the next Hulk film
could be like a Captain America Civil
War film The Hulk going up against his
son scar with some people taking sides
but the best part about this is
apparently we are supposed to be getting
a full on Hulk again just a full-on rage
monster destroying everything in his
path getting angrier and angrier
stronger and stronger until he's
Unstoppable and I do think that they'll
announce some type of Hulk project
coming in phase six now the next project
that I think is going to get decent
attention is blade they didn't really
talk about it at sdcc but I think that
we're going to be getting our first look
at mahershala Ali in his blade outfit I
also think that they're going to reveal
the villain of the movie and rumor has
it recently that it could be Denzel
Washington some Insiders on Twitter
recently have been posting a list of
names and others have been retweeting
this list as well Denzel Washington was
on that list we didn't really know what
he was up for at the time but rumor has
it that it could be the villain of Blade
and I'm expecting a first look at blade
and Hope hopefully that villain reveal
now another big one is Nova and we'll
get into that but first thank you to
best fiends for sponsoring this video I
think we all know how much pressure life
can put on us sometimes and I know it's
really easy to put off having a little
bit of relaxation time and a little bit
of fun but that shouldn't be how it is
and with best fiends and exciting puzzle
Adventure game you can have fiendish fun
anywhere anytime best fiends is an
awesome puzzle game that I truly enjoy
because it's not just connecting in
straight lines but you can actually
connect diagonally which is a lot more
fun and you can play it anytime because
it's super quick to play and you level
up very very easily in fact the first
time I played it for only a few minutes
I got all the way to level six that's
because this game is really easy to just
pick up and get in the zone because it's
super fun one second you're on level one
and then the next thing you know you've
connected enough times to get to level
six and there are literally thousands of
different levels you can play and the
best part is best fiends is free to
download so don't put off your fun time
anymore you've definitely earned it go
to the app store or Google play to
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level 5.
that's best fiends without the r now
Nova's a big one it's been confirmed by
deadline that Nova is indeed coming to
the MCU there's a project in the works
right now and the latest rumor has it
that Nova has actually been cast and
this is going to be a huge reveal and
I'm expecting this to be announced at
d23 the latest rumors have it that it's
either going to be John boyega from Star
Wars that's going to play Nova or Ryan
Gosling I talked about this in
yesterday's video I definitely think
that either could do a great job I'm
open to seeing what John boyega could
bring to the role but I do think that
Ryan Gosling would make a perfect Nova
hopefully we find out who's playing him
tomorrow now another project that I hope
gets announced I haven't really heard
much about it but I hope a solo Scarlet
Witch film gets announced ever since
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness came out a bunch of insiders
have said that a Scarlet Witch solo
project a true one is in the works now
we haven't heard much since then but if
we think about it it just makes sense we
know that she's not dead and the writer
for Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness Michael Waldron basically
confirmed she's not dead so it would
make sense that she has to show up again
before the events of Secret Wars because
if she doesn't it doesn't really make
sense we can't just have her you know
threaten the entire Multiverse go away
and come back and be like oh hey let me
help you save the Multiverse again there
has to be some Arc leading up to that
she can't just flip the switch from
villain to Hero so easily especially
when she killed a lot of sorcerers at
the karmotage so it would make sense
that a solo Scarlet Witch Project would
come before the King Dynasty and Secret
Wars now I'm expecting two more really
big things to happen at d23 and the
first one is the trailer for Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania the trailer was
already shown at sdcc however it was not
released to the public this time I
believe they'll show it again but
actually release it to the public now to
add on that I also do think we'll
probably get a second trailer for
wakanda forever but I do hope we get
that official trailer for Ant-Man 3. and
of course the last major thing that I'm
expecting to happen is the cast for The
Fantastic Four to be revealed now here's
where it gets a little bit tricky based
off of what I've heard they have already
picked the cast however there have been
many conflicting reports recently on who
the actual cast seems to be I will say
that it does seem like Jody Comer is
going to be playing Sue storm the
invisible woman that seems to be pretty
solid however there are a lot of
conflicting reports about John Krasinski
as Mr Fantastic some people say that he
is going to be playing him some people
say that he's not John krasinski's name
does seem to be attached to a recent and
upcoming MCU project however we don't
know what capacity that's in he could be
directing some type of Marvel movie
because I don't think it makes sense for
him to play another character after we
saw him as Mr Fantastic so this one's
kind of up in the air he could be
playing Mr Fantastic or he might not be
and like I mentioned yesterday the other
names that we've heard are Seth Rogen as
the thing which honestly I'm down for
and Ross Lynch as the Human Torch that
is the most recent that I've heard
however of course that's not set in
stone it's just a rumor for now but I do
hope that they revealed the official
cast or at least give us something for
the Fantastic Four but again like I've
said it does seem like the cast has been
locked in now the one final thing that I
think we might get and this is a big
might but that is the casting of Henry
Cavill as Hyperion who could be
appearing in Loki season 2 leading the
Squadron Supreme which he does in the
comics now this has actually been
rumored for quite some time now and I'm
really hoping it's real I would love
Henry Cavill and the MCU and I think he
would make a great Hyperion and I think
him and Tom Hiddleston interacting with
each other and Owen Wilson in Loki
season 2 would be pretty dang cool to
watch so I'm really crossing my fingers
for an announcement there now the last
one that I really don't know about is
Spider-Man Spider-Man seems to have some
sort of a presence at d23 but again the
reports and rumors about this are very
conflicting some say that it's is going
to be a new announcement about an MCU
movie some say that it has nothing to do
with the MCU or The Amazing Spider-Man
3. so Spider-Man is kind of a wild card
right now as to what's going to happen
with him in any type of announcements at
d23 now we're at the end of the video
and I'm sure you're wondering well hey
what about the X-Men what about the
mutants and right now honestly we have
about a 50 50 shot of hearing something
about the mutants you see the mutants
are actually kind of going to be the
main focus of phase 7 and Beyond they're
going to have a part in secret Wars but
they're not going to be really the main
figures of phase six however there is
the possibility that Marvel Studios
could start to introduce New Mutants in
phase six we already have Kamala Khan
introduced as the first official mutant
of the MCU but we know that others are
out there we also know that Marvel
Studios has already started casting for
the X-Men but are they far enough along
have they casted who they needed to cast
to do an official announcement for an
official mutants project it also depends
on what they want to do do they want to
dedicate an entire project to the
mutants or start to introduce them in
other projects like I said mutants
aren't going to be a primary focus
leading up to Avengers Secret Wars but
they are going to play a part so we
might not actually get anything as far
as the mutants are concerned at d23 it
could be that the only thing we get is
Kevin feige stating hey they're coming
you'll see them in other projects but
they won't get an official project to
themselves before phase seven so like I
said this one's kind of up in the air
hopefully we find out something tomorrow
but in the meantime like I said I'll be
covering this all day tomorrow so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the reveals don't forget to
like the video as it helps the channel
and of course if you want to follow for
live updates tomorrow you can follow me
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof